hello internet friends I'm Seb forward
and you're watching a GameSpot news
update Pikachu has thundered back into
the arena not as a peddler of lethal
electric shocks to the tune of pika pika
Pikachu but as Japan's official mascot
for the 2014 FIFA World Cup adidas and
the Pokemon company have announced that
the adorable Electric Mouse is the
official mascot for the Japanese
football team but this summer's 2014
FIFA World Cup in Brazil Pikachu
indubitably the team captain will be
joined on the Pokemon squads by meow
Bulbasaur Charmander squirtle chespin
froakie fennekin Pancham helioptile and
litleo the promotion features Pikachu
and pals dressed up in Japan's official
kit for the tournament the mascot for
the tournament itself is a yellow and
blue armadillo named Bullock oh it's
unknown where falaqa would fit on the
Pokemon type chart but it's probably a
safe bet that Pikachu would beat him in
a fight
Esper will not be there to terrify the
opposition sadly the 2014 World Cup
begins on June 12th
Japan's opponents include the Ivory
Coast Greece and Colombia would you pick
or choose a different Pokemon to be your
country's mascot and do Pokemon know
about the offside rule all of these
questions and more are answered in our
Pokemon X&Y review and for all things
Pokemon make sure to keep it here at
GameSpot